the sequel to the haunting of hill house
one of my favorite shows of 2018
is coming back this fall with an
entirely new haunted house called bly
manor
today vanity fair released a slew of new
information and photos which
yes do contain hidden ghosts so i
figured let's take a little visit to
blime manor and figure out everything we
know so far
first thing to note the official
haunting of hill house twitter account
has changed its name to the haunting of
bly manor
and it's also updated its banner with
the first official poster and of course
there's a little hidden easter egg where
the account says to
look beneath the surface and if you zoom
in on the water you can make out the
reflections of
characters in the show and speaking of
characters look who's made a return in
this creepy basement full of dolls
you might remember actress victoria
pedretti who played nell
in the first season she's back playing
an entirely different character named
danny clayton fun fact her last name is
an homage to jack clayton the director
of the 1961 film adaptation of the turn
of the screw the book bly manor is based
off unlike turn of the screw which takes
place in the late 1800s
blime manor is set in 1987. however
knowing how hill house turned out i
wouldn't be surprised if the new season
jumps back and forth in time the season
is also based on two other henry james
stories the jolly corner and the romance
of certain old clothes the jolly corner
is about a man who believes a ghostly
alter ego is following him while
the romance of certain old clothes
revolves around a
chest that may or may not contain
violent ghosts
and look at this a chest in this set
photo whether this relates to that story
we just simply don't know yet but back
to this photo of danny clayton
this is the basement of bly manor which
houses a collection of creepy ass dolls
now i'll give you a minute to try and
find the hidden ghost in this picture
i'm not gonna lie it took me forever and
i had to zoom in i'll also include a
link to the vanity fair article if you
want to
zoom in on a better quality photo but
before i show you where it is
there's a few things to cover danny here
is an american tutor who has taken a job
abroad
looking after the wingrave children
miles and flora we don't know much about
her other than she has a quote
painful pass the dolls apparently play a
large role in the season in fact
creator mike flanagan is quoted as
saying they play a key role in
understanding the mystery of bly manor
whereas season one focused heavily on
family season two is about broken hearts
and star-crossed romance but like season
one i can't help but think the creepy
walls in the back here look oddly like
the mouldy walls in the basement of hell
house now if you haven't found the ghost
i'm gonna zoom in but
it's gonna be pretty blurry here he is
the hidden ghosts in season one were
kind of a fun easter egg that really
didn't impact the story
but flanagan says in season two they are
quote puzzles to be solved and that
we'll find out who they are and why
they're there
now we don't really get a good look at
the exterior of blind manor just a
little outline in the poster but it will
apparently contrast hill house by being
more welcoming in comparison to
hellhouse's
gothic and ominous presence in this
photo we get our first look at the
manager of blind manor hannah gross
played by tania miller
with the two orphan wingrave children in
the background there's not much to
dissect here other than the cross
necklace around hannah's neck
she's a character taken directly from
the novel who's said to be in denial
about what's going on i'm wondering how
her christian faith will reconcile the
ghostly entities haunting bly manor now
you might remember this guy
actor henry thomas who played the
patriarch of the crane family in
hill house also elliot and e.t i don't
care what the president says he's my
best friend
he'll be back playing the wealthy uncle
of the orphans but it appears he wants
nothing to do with his niece and nephew
and just
monetarily helps them i can't help but
think he knows something more about
blimey manor and that his hesitance to
visit
is fueled by this knowledge now you
might remember oliver jackson cohen the
actor who played the addicted brother
luke crane in season 1. well he's got a
totally new role playing the villain
peter quint in the book peter is an evil
spirit who comes to haunt and possess
the young boy miles
in this version he's a business
associate of the uncles who wants blind
manner and will do anything to have it
next we have a look at flora next to the
former governess rebecca jessel played
by tahirah sharif in the books the
former governess fear she's going mad
not a good omen for flora this will
likely provide the catalyst for dany
arriving at the manor
see here how she's holding one of
flora's handmade dolls and i can't help
but think if this is something similar
to what dany is holding in the basement
perhaps dany takes it upon herself to
solve the mystery of this former
governess
a governess she is told killed herself
there's also this picture of flora by
the lake holding an even more handmade
type doll in the books the main
character believes miss jaisal's ghost
is corrupting flora while peter quince
ghost is corrupting miles
peter and miss jessel apparently had an
inappropriate relationship
so maybe that had something to do with
the former governess's tragic death
moving on to the brother miles and he
just looks like that quintessential
creepy horror movie kid
and i'm really excited to see the acting
here since mike flanagan did an amazing
job with the child actors in season 1.
behind him is dany which hints that this
is his room in bly manor here we see mrs
gross with the chef
owen but there are two things here that
are just a bit weird
the car to the left is very old not
really indicative of 1987
and take a look at this obelisk in the
back these are usually
found in graveyards now in the novella
the former governess body
is buried in the bly manor churchyard
could this
possibly be that yard finally we have
actress amelia eve
playing groundskeeper jaime she's
described as a self-confident skeptic
but other than that there's not much we
know about her not pictured are hill
house season 1 carla gugino and kate
siegel carla will be voicing the
narrator and kate's role is still under
wraps
so i hope you enjoyed this quick
breakdown of the new details coming out
about the show
i'm super excited and i hope you'll give
this video a like and subscribe as i'll
be covering
everything bly manor for more bad takes
follow me on twitter at thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much